foreign
there are two pugs okay they're puppies
nice what are the names uh Leon and
Winnie my wife named her Winnie dogs are
the best how how's their breathing
one of them is real rough but you know
the dog joke was it a pun no no no no
yeah
I spelled it out of my head r-o-u-g-h no
but they're they're real yeah that's not
funny
what I liked it Anthony would have been
busting up in the corner to hear that
one no but uh they're they're puppies
and we the story's crazy we found my
mother-in-law found a uh a pug which is
on the street she brought him in and
then she was pregnant she had eight
puppies so she took two of them
junkyard in Tucson Arizona oh wow a
beautiful place I used to be a dog
person but then I I turned into a cat
person how does that like a yeah yeah so
it's like you know
so I started off uh really liking dogs
but then
um I didn't have a dog anymore and then
I lived uh in a place where there was a
bunch of stray cats that are coming
around all the time and they're like
kittens wait hold on I think you skipped
a big part you said you're a dog person
and then you just didn't like dogs
anymore yeah like yeah well because no
no I had a dog and then that dog was
taken away okay so then I did it once I
lived without a dog I was like I was
kind of nice I don't have to take care I
keep skipping bro you know when you have
a dog like you get used to this pace of
Life yeah like okay I gotta walk a dog
in here yeah yeah yeah right but then
when that goes away you're like oh I can
breathe yeah it's like a single again
yeah basically it happened when I was
single actually and then after that I'm
just like gonna get a little lonely and
then all of a sudden these little
kittens come by my house and I'm like oh
you know what I'm gonna try to you know
give them a little food here and there
and they start coming every day and I'm
like oh dang this is crazy this is kind
of cool because like it's like you don't
expect stray animals to like be so
curious because dogs they get they just
run away sometimes most most stray dogs
they just run away but these cats are
like they're just coming by so I feed
them they get older and now uh one of
the cats that really likes me has
kittens oh [__] now I'm like I get to
see their whole life process I'm like
damn I'm a cat person now and superhero
origin story yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but I am giving those kids out for
adoption because I don't want them to
keep reading Eggs
cool though because like they're so
different than dogs they're just like
calm they're quiet they're curious they
want to see what you're doing but dude
dogs can be calm and quiet too man yeah
I know they could be curious you don't
have
because this is a really really super
jacked up story all right this is in
Illinois there's a woman
um she has a Boston Terrier what a
[__] [__] dude what already another
lady no wait no she's good she's good
she's got a the dog's 10 years old
loves this dog
um the dog escaped the yard so first
thing she does is she calls animal
shelter and they said yeah Peanut's here
you can pick her up in the morning she's
like oh thank God she goes there in the
morning dog's not there they say oh uh
actually your dog is in the animal
hospital she goes to the Animal Hospital
dog's not there either they're like oh
it's actually at the clinic she goes to
the clinic this is just the next day by
the way the clinic goes oh yeah um we
put her to sleep
oh my God yep why did they put her down
she pretend because they found the dog
had like you know like dog did little
tumors and stuff they found a little
tumor on it so they just euthanized it
whoa that's [__] up that's somebody's
dog they didn't hit her up and she just
found it yesterday
what a roller coaster of emotion bad
communication like it's a straight up
tag dog because you know when they uh I
would have beat that vet ass
when I ask Ed is like sure deserving
remember anything did she take anything
as of yet no no it's just it's just what
do you call it like they just suck at
telling the next Department someone's
picking up yeah like whoever picked up
the phone could have just forgot or just
wrote it down or like they didn't tell
the the morning shift hey she's coming
to pick up her dog right like you know
um okay so you know what the pound they
they're just that's all they do is they
just euthanize dogs all [__] they
just are they just volunteers or do they
actually get paid or volunteer to
euthanize dogs
the pound you come in you pay them a
hundred dollars
why would they be so like bad at their
job like that well no they're good
they're good at their jobs they're so
good at killing dogs I'm a merchant of
death
oh my God no I like animal services
right like they're they're paid
government employees right I don't know
about small towns and if they have
enough money for this stuff but the
sheer scale if you live in a major city
of how many lost dogs they find and they
they're just Strays or whatever and no
one like picks them up they don't have
enough space yeah yeah and then that's
why the shelters all the all they do is
just it's just a kill Farm like they're
like up time's up and then but I don't
know like within a 24-hour period that
is that's freaking weird the thing is
that they did they said oh we did try to
call but when they looked at the record
at like the third place the phone number
was off by a digit in the paperwork see
negligence yeah it's just one day
imagine going the morning after but what
if that clinic is like they Pride
themselves on how quick they do yeah
yeah we'll have you know we put down the
most dogs on the first day we find them
at any [__] Hospital in the country
yeah we are better than everyone yeah
yeah oh my God maybe you shouldn't have
lost your [__] dog yeah kinda though
right honestly yeah I think she'll get
another one now oh my God filter right
it's refresh if you have any like Ring
app or anything to all day people are
losing dogs
they need like a find my iPhone for your
dog bro you can tag it it just starts
making a noise
I've been seeing lost parrots
people are like in the past five days I
saw one lost parrot entry like every day
and I'm like this is just it's not a
troll yeah yeah yeah like are you not
joking like how do you suppose the Ring
app Community is gonna find your [__]
parrot does it matter we just need to
find him
don't belong in cages man yeah that's
true that's the other thing though too
but someone's binoculars are like oh
there goes Johnson's parrot we found him
yeah it's like how do you find a parent
we have runs away all the time she's a
grown-ass woman that's just Huskies
though huh yeah five or six years old
yeah I guess Huskies Just Bounce
like she's also like I will say she's
probably the smartest dog I've ever had
is she like the Escape expert escape art
we don't know we don't know how she does
it like even we have cameras and it's
like she turns them off
until the movement stops right so like
she always hits out to the back but
somehow we can never get it on camera
the only way we know she gets out is we
get a call what's happened we're so used
to so the motion doesn't work ghost
like no it works we've also got we've
got some other [__] on there like she
killed a big ass rat one time that was
[__] cool but she just gets out we're
used to her just we're used to waking up
to phone calls like hey we have ghosts
we have ghosts he's over here neighbor's
yard or sometimes she goes far what's
the farthest you picked her up Culver
City like deep into Culver like I live
in mid city which is like I'm probably
on a five minute drive to the tip of
Culver but like she was like a 10 minute
drive
on foot she was trekking she was gone
and she was just I've seen her like I
let her up the leash one time like we
were already almost going to walk all
right girls go ahead and instead of just
going to the house she went past the
house and ran into oncoming traffic oh
Fairfax but then dodged like four cars
expertly and kept going wow
she just does this [__] I don't know
I don't know that's crazy much pressure
with a dog man because they've run away
so much like well with huskies like
that's what they're no it's like a game
I don't [__] get it they're known for
being hella smart and they're like chase
me
notice how much you love him come get me
anxiety ridden huh no now we're kind of
cool about it because like we don't see
ghosts like all right we're gonna call
them the next hour so what a good name
you know yeah
yeah and the gate in our crib like we
have like a mechanical gate the company
is called Ghost Protocol
it's crazy it doesn't stop ghosts it
doesn't stop her I'll let you know yeah
so
so you got to figure out how she gets
out it's out of curiosity I want to know
I don't [__] people they were saying
that they get air tags like the apple
one yeah
and they put it on the the dog they
probably have collars and stuff now too
with the permanent chip yeah do you know
about air tags yeah somebody just got
their car back off air tag you hear
about that yeah I marked that dude
killed the dude yeah that's crazy yeah
Texas style
find out and kill the guy who stole your
car I am yeah
they must thank you to Antonio Lopez for
submitting that article
[Music]